yeah I'm going to tell you a story but
what I thought I'd start with is a
little puzzle and then while people are
thinking about the puzzle I'll tell you
a little story one of the big legends of
mathematics and then we'll see what the
answer to the puzzle was the puzzle is
fairly easy to state I just want you to
add up the digits from one to a million
now I want you to add up all the digits
if you imagine if you wrote out the
numbers one to a million I want you to
add up all the digits not the numbers so
if I want to say 123 plus 124 that's not
what I want to do I want to add up all
the digits of those numbers one plus two
plus three plus one plus two plus four
imagine writing a list of all the
numbers from one to a million with all
those digits and I want you to add up
all the digits and what answer will you
get while you think about that I'm going
to tell you one of these famous
mathematical stories
so this is the story of Gauss Carl Gauss
Carl Gauss is possibly one of the
greatest mathematicians of the last few
hundred years he's really is a really
large figure now the story goes that
when he was nine he started to attend at
school his arithmetic class now
arithmetic class would include you know
lots of boys all the way up to the age
of 15 imagine like this is 1780 we're
talking about long time ago imagine it's
a it's a drab schoolroom and it's very
worn and the floor was uneven and the
teacher was also drab and worn and
uneven himself in it apparently he was
quite a bully he would walk around with
his cane and he would thrash the boys
now one day to keep them quiet
you know this will keep him quiet for an
hour he gave them a problem to add up
all the numbers from one to a hundred
so add up all the numbers to one to a
hundred
so one plus two plus three plus four
plus all the way up to 100 right that
was the problem he gave that the pupils
and they had to write on slate in those
days and when you got the solution you
were to put your slate on the teachers
table now Gauss when he was given this
problem immediately threw his slate on
to the teachers table with an answer now
the other boys continued their work
adding up all the numbers multiplying
and adding and subtracting whatever they
had to do thus brute of a teacher
strolled around the classroom throwing
us pitying looks at poor Gauss that's
guessing the answer and throwing it onto
the table when the hour was over he took
the stack of slates turn them over so
that Gauss's answer was on the top and
read out the answer to his astonishment
he got the answer right the answer was
5050 which mean that Gauss was able to
solve it in seconds how do you solve it
well he had a trick the trick was he
noticed that if you add
the numbers in pairs I'm gonna start
with one and I'm going to add it to a
hundred what you get is one hundred and
one
now if you take the second number and
add it to the second-to-last number 99
you get one hundred and one you take
three and add it to ninety eight you get
one hundred and one in fact each pair
that you make that in this way will
equal one hundred and one how many pairs
do you make well there's a hundred there
fifty pairs you make so he just took 101
times it by fifty and he got 5050 so
this story was first written about in an
obituary by one of Cole Gauss's friends
apparently Cole gautsche would tell this
story himself so it seems to be fairly
true some embellishments over the years
have been the brutishness of this
teacher with this cane and his thrashing
that's been added on to over the years
and the problem I gave you about adding
the numbers 1 to 100 that's been added
on to over the years as well we don't
know what the original problem was so to
finish our puzzle now maybe you've got
time to think we're going to use this
method that well gals may have used to
solve his problem but we were adding the
numbers 1 to a million but we weren't
adding the numbers I mean it I I threw
in a twist we were adding all the digits
of the numbers so let's just write out
the numbers first I'll start with 1 then
I'll have 2 & 3 & 4 I'm going to skip a
few and then we'll go to the end so
let's go to something like nine hundred
and ninety-nine thousand nine hundred
and ninety five nine hundred ninety nine
thousand nine
six gamer know her in 99019 nine and
that's half 1 million there we go
right so we were going to add up all the
digits though well how about this let's
just start with the zero I'm going to
add on the zero I didn't see that before
but I sat on the zero there at the front
if I use pairs zero paired up with
999,999 if you add those together you
get this number
999,999 if we try this pair we get the
same answer of course and two Plus this
one do three and nine hundred ninety
nine thousand nine hundred ninety six
and four with nine hundred ninety nine
thousand nine hundred ninety five and
all those pairs equal the same thing now
if all those pairs equal the same thing
we can now add up these digits and this
gives me what does this give nine plus
nine plus nine plus nine plus nine plus
nine fifty four and how many pairs have
I made half a million times half a
million which is equal to it's actually
equal to twenty-seven million so all the
digits added up to 27 million except I
have left out my million there I didn't
add that in my pair did I so that's out
of those digits do that is one so we add
that on and so the answer is adding all
the numbers all the digits of the
numbers from one to a million is
twenty-seven million and one using
Gauss's trick at this point you can go
wild right how many how many arrows do
you want so the next one let's say we
did three ^ ^ ^ arrow arrow or whatever
you want to call this three will that
that